[Music]
27 year old alejandro carion is a man
involved in the killing 64 year old
woman now identified as susan villa
carion is charged with dui possession of
psychedelic mushrooms and cocaine the
accident happened over the holiday on
farm road near tenea way which is up in
centennial hills sally jaramillo tells
us a lot of people who live nearby are
frustrated sally
yes they are and people in this
neighborhood really hope for more
policing of this intersection
early monday morning police say a
bicyclist witnessed a crash and call
9-1-1 the chevy tahoe was heading east
on farm crossed over the center median
into the west lanes hitting susan
biela's prius sharon linzenbard has
lived in the area for 53 years and says
that intersection is dangerous for those
walking and driving we need more police
out here
we
we need to have everybody be aware that
people live out here it's so unnecessary
to have people die in car crashes within
a couple miles of your home carrion
faces charges of dui above the legal
limit resulting in death reckless
driving resulting in death or severe
bodily harm two counts possession of
controlled substance failure to wear a
seat belt failure to maintain lane
driving without a license
i spoke to a friend of susan villa
obviously friends and family in shock
tonight as susan was described as a
smart beautiful human being also
described as a wonderful friend
reporting live sally jaramillo 8 news
now